you been any Vegas strip clubs not at
all you gotta go I stay away from strip
clubs why
just a smart thing to do save your
dollars no you go and you eat
you go and eat you got to go and get the
chicken wings out or eat chicken see I
don't got no reason at the club are you
a vegan something like that what's that
mean a vegan are you vegan I'm uh I'm a
picky eater I'm tired of the titles you
feel me I feel like you don't eat
chicken no I don't have a chicken in
probably like 12 years why so good so
where do you get your protein from
it's a lot of yeah we're not even finna
dive all the way do you eat fish where
do cows get their protein from what
about gorillas
this guy's [__] this guy right here
is the same he's like yeah you tell them
[__]
so you don't eat fish or anything yeah
you fish occasionally that's like the
only thing I go to as far as when's the
last time you had a steak
I don't think I ever had a steak in my
life oh yeah I've never liked even as a
kid a poor guy and like too chewy you
don't you never had in and out
yeah I probably had it now when I was
younger
you don't eat burgers veggie burgers
it's the same thing it's 20 23. you're
trying to tell me a veggie burger that
tastes like ass cheeks is the same you
ever have Burger guys nobody wants none
of that [__] shut up Burger guys
black independent shout out to them
support them they going crazy
fire better than in and out better than
everything you're a [__] liar don't
tell people that this is crazy this is
I'm serious try it so you okay on a
daily basis you wait like are you eating
salads all [__] day peanut butter
what are you eating
uh I eat everything you a regular person
eats just a veggie style a lot of potato
chips a lot of cereal I am a heavy
potato chip eater unfortunately that's
what's your favorite choice
I like hot Cheetos that's just gonna
[__] you up it will you won't need a
steak but you can eat that [__] I
know yeah tell me about it what do you
think is worse for you
the steak is a [__] hot cheese steak
you're [__] crazy what about do you
eat a lot of cereal
I don't eat cereal at all never in life
no I'm more of a fruit guy before Syria
as a kid you didn't eat cereal yeah
growing up I ate you know you never
busted cinnamon toast 9 pm bowl of Lucky
Charms nah yeah I'm a noodles type of
guy like Ramen 12 a.m 12 a.m
do you have anything special with the
noodles are we putting any sort of hot
sauce or cheese or anything nah you're
going too crazy we're not in jail now
we're gonna eat them regular we're
making a spread we gotta get you some
cereal and some steak what's your
favorite cereal ever
it goes back and forth I got three who's
the one with the frog on it that used to
be fine smacks I love uh I like peanut
butter crunch even though it [__] the
roof of your mouth up yeah I like
Applejacks
and Lucky Charms
everything was sugar
let's say you used to put the extra
sugar you know how people put that only
in Cheerios you get the norm the regular
Cheerios you put the sugar in it yeah
that's real ghetto is it ghetto real
unhealthy you eat hot cheetos I don't
want to hear steak Yeah
steak is good it's dead
well I mean would you rather me bite a
live Cow's Ass you know I actually I
don't judge you have a [__] lettuce
says the guy with the dead the dead cow
on his [__] coat right now Hamilton
come on man oh you're too good to eat it
but you'll wear the cow this is Jeff
Hamilton it's different it's premium
you're you know what you are you're a
hypocrite
you're right I am all right well listen
man I'm human that's what I am
everybody's a hypocrite yeah look we got
to get you on some [__] meat bruh
pause you know what I mean don't matter
y'all have a good day last uh the new
single with Roddy rich is out everywhere
requested obviously the four pack is out
um just for clarity two absolutely album
before the end of the year it's or we
don't know yet we don't know yet we're
very methodical yeah yeah yeah too early
we're gonna be in your face though
regardless pause okay and uh is the
video was everybody out yet no it's not
it's dropping real soon did you direct
it
There It Is Well look go support this
guy
um we need to start a GoFundMe for him
to be better we just all need to just
get you some kobe beef yeah you're rich
we don't need to give you a GoFundMe we
need to take you to a nice steakhouse
cereal fun Vic are you on the same level
good at least not everyone in your
team's insane
yeah
fish okay yeah
steak buddy picky eater you like chicken
nuggets hell no vegan chicken nuggets
hell yeah that [__] is
that [__] it tastes like [__] first
of all they can't coach I'm tired of
these vegan [__] calling things vegan
something yeah like vegan chicken wings
it's too Politico for sure just call it
like a chickpea ball it's not a [__]
chicken anyway that's how we end the
interview guys dietary yeah my guy
appreciate you brother appreciate it yes
sir